When we get there. How do you want to handle
the entrances? Maybe you introduce me.
Introduce. Come in.
This is a table read. Charles. It's not the
Donna Reed show. Donna Reed was not worth it.
Okay, now, please do not start this journey
by alienating all of your colleagues with
some desperate attempt at peacocking. No
peacocking.
Oliver Putnam, India.
Oh my God! You.
Oh my God. Loretta. Where is Loretta?
Loretta is in her dressing room. She is
pretty upset, but she said she'll try to make
the party.
Are you sure a party is a.
You know.
What? No, no no no.
Spit it out, Charles Heep some more suffering
onto my already full plate. There might be a
little room next to the despair, and she's
going with me. What are in it?
And you can tell those workers on stage right
now that if anyone lays another finger on my
sets, I'm going to wrestle them to an Oliver
Putnam never taps out.
You've had a minor heart attack.
Oh my God, dad!
You said Minor Willy, I mean. That's just a
rite of passage in the theater. You know, Bob
Fosse had, like, five. Yeah.
You know, the last one killed him, right?
Oh, you did read his biography.
Uh, there are a few things we need to talk
about. First is your blood pressure. It's 160
over 100.
And. Is that high?
Yes.
And it's high. Good. No.
Uh, I'm going to prescribe you some
medications, but you need to change your diet
to cut out dips.
Doctor, are you trying to kill me?
Who goes there?
The creatures all come down.
Right?
Well, it's a start. Uh, give me, uh, 1 or 2
seconds to to to collect my thoughts.
Okay.
Yes. Fruit pie ma'am.
Ah, your dreams are just now.
Welcome. Oh, and you're your own Satan.
Yes.
Like a good neighbor. State farm is there.
Out, out, out. I'm just saying that maybe
alternative financing might reduce your
stress.
Well, guys, we are so, so close.
Why don't we start fresh tomorrow morning?
Hi. Hi.
Before I tell you what I'm about to tell you,
I need your assurance that you will not be
angry.
No.
No one wants to do the musical. Oh.
No. One. Oh.
The cast. Most of the people who would do it,
they don't want to do it. Are.
They didn't want to do the musical. That's
fine.
Perhaps they'd rather I take this spoon and
stab myself in the eye with it, and just stab
and stab.
So I'll be too dead to be humiliated when
Donna and Cliff get here, which is five
minutes from now.
I think they're just scared. They don't
understand the show, and I don't either, to
be fair, but I come from television and I was
trained not to question a script.
I have a theory. Yeah. Goldie, the wardrobe
lady.
Why do you say that?
Because she's utterly replaceable. It won't
affect our show one way or another. If
Goldie, the wardrobe lady, goes to jail. The
key here is to find a murderer that won't
cost me the Tony.
Great. That was a real help.
Well, my pants are still on, so that's a good
sign.
I have never heard filth like what just came
out of your mouth. Tom is.
A Christian. Charles.
Take the day, Tom. Find a priest. Pray it
out. It's so
solid, so fully formed, you know.
Damn broiler. I know it's.
Oh, hell, I'm just gonna look at this. Ooh.
That's what I'm gonna. Wow. What? Why cut it?
Why not? Well.
So good.
Oh.
God. Oh my God.
I'm so sorry. Oh, is that mine?
Oh, I'm so mortified. Let me get you some ice
or something. No, no, no.
I don't I actually don't feel anything.
Sure. No.
Oh, God.
Oh. I love that little snort.
You do? You do?
Yeah, I do.
You're like an adorable little piglet.
Oliver, I should warn you, when I commit to a
show, I commit fully.
Oh, I love it. You would be surprised how
often people are half in, half out. Oh,
Oliver, my kids need me. Oh, Oliver. My
girlfriend left me. I only have a little
fishy left, and I'm afraid of being alone. I
mean, this is the theater. What else even is
there?
I agree totally, so I think I understand the
constable, but I'm going to need your help to
become the constable. It's part of my
process. When I did wargames, I taught myself
to write code.
Incredible.
For my role in election, I started teaching
high school and dating some students.
Okay. Go home.
Excuse me.
Go home.
I've had enough of your inane questions,
Matthew Broderick. Nobody cares what
denomination the constable is or how he'd
finger a mandolin. The constable is just the
constable. His parents didn't name him Rocky
or Lawrence or Bernardo. You know why?
Because he doesn't have any parents. He's
just six grams of ink on paper. A few
electrons in my hard disk. That's it. I can
wake up tomorrow, and I can hit the delete
key and poof, he'd be gone. Eradicated from
this musical. Exiled from our reality. Gone
like a rat in a microwave.
Oh, okay.
Well, see you tomorrow morning, 6 a.m. Nova
Scotia time.
Uh.
Oh, I'm not lurking.
Uh, Lester wanted to inspect the peep holes
because evidently some of them had been
installed backwards. So I said, well, I'll do
it. And he said, you know, the good time is 2
a.m., so I'm lying. I just wanted to say I'm
sorry.
Oh. Apology accepted. Friendship mended.
You're hired. No, no. Hello, everyone.
Oh, Oliver, we have a big problem.
Your cardio.
Conditioning.
Yes, that is a big problem. But that is not
this big problem. It's Jonathan. He can't go
on. He's taken a bunch of pills and he is
completely out of it.
The leading man cocktail.
Jesus, why are you a coat stand?
Howard, Jonathan has got to go on. Who's
going to replace our leading man on five
minutes notice?
I don't know, but we'll need someone who
knows his every line. Someone who studied his
every gesture, his every intonation. Someone
who never sought the spotlight but is willing
to accept the weight of the detective's hat.
How are you saying that? I think you're
saying.
At the edge of the world. In the dead of the
night, a lighthouse looms over the ocean.
And a body lies curled.
Such a sinister sight. Guts and gore on the
shore. Nova Scotian.
Was that a blood curdling cry or the innocent
sigh of a child?
Well, it rattles your soul as the dark takes
control. It's enough to drive you wild.
When? Creature.
The night.
All alone in the black. Feel your sanity
crack a creature.
On the.
Board. Wade's first quadruple threat can
sing, dance, direct or act.
You got a lot of fun.
You creature of the night.